If you've got a function f of x,
you know the value at some point and you wanted to go to the neighboring point
or distance delta x away you ask how much does the function change
and the answer it is the change in the function felt that f is the deliver to of
the function at the starting point times the distance you move.
This is not any quality unless f happens to be a straight line.
It's an approximation and that our connections to this,
that's what all the dots mean.
Corrections are proportional,
the delta x squared,
x cubed and so on,
but if delta x is tiny,
this will do.
That's it.
But today we are going to move the whole work energy DRM and the law of
conservation of energy to two dimensions.
So when you go to two dimensions,
you've got to ask yourself,
what am I looking for?
Well,
in the end I'm hoping I will get some relation like k one plus you one his kid
too,
plus you to assuming that there's no friction.
Youtube is going to be my new potential energy.
Then if it's a potential energy and the particles moving into two dimensions,
it's got to be a function of two variables,
x and y.
So I have to make sure that you guys know enough about functions of more than
one variable.
So this is again crash course on reminding you of the main points that are not
that many.
By the time I get here,
I'll be done.
So how do visualize the function of two variables function.
One variable,
you know you plot x this way in the function along why if it's two variables,
you products here and why here and the function itself is shown by drawing some
surface on pop of the x,
y plane so that if you take a point and you go right up until he hit the
surface,
that's the value of the function at that point.
X,
Y,
it's like a canopy on top of the x,
y plane and how high you got to go.
It's the function.
For example,
starting with the floor,
I can ask her,
why do I have to go until I hit the ceiling?
That function varies that Benson Bimble dimples and was so on.
So the function Betty's with x,
y now that example of a function of x and y,
x and y,
it could be coordinates in the United States and the function could be the
temperature at that point.
So your product on top of that,
each point you plot the temperature at that point.
So once you got the notion of a function of two variables,
if you're going to do calculus,
the next thing is what about the date of it is are the function,
how does it change?
But in the old days it was dependent on x and I changed the ex and I found the
change in the function divided by the change in accident took the limit and that
became my dinner.
Now I was sitting in the x,
y plane.
So he had this accent here.
This is why I'm here.
The function is coming out of the blackboard.
So imagine something measured out.
But I'm sitting here now I want to move and ask how the function changes.
But now I have a lot of options.
In fact,
I'm infinite number of options.
I can move along X.
I can move along.
Why I can load some intermediate angle.
Do you have to ask what do you want me to do when it comes to time to take
derivatives so it turns out and you will see it proven amply as we go along that
you just have to think about derivatives on two principle directions which I
will choose to be x and y.
So we're going to define one date of active which is defined as follows.
You start at the point x,
y you go to the point x plus Delta x same way and subtract the function at the
starting point.
They by Delta x and take all the limits.
Delta x goes to zero.
That means you go from here to here,
you move a distance,
Delta x,
you'd find the change of the function.
You take the derivative as you move horizontally,
you notice you don't do anything to why,
why will be left fixed at whatever.
Why you had x will be changed by Delta x.
You find the change,
you take the debt of active and take the limit that has been altered by the
symbol,
the FDX.
So this curly d instead of the straight D is to tell you it's called a partial
derivative.
Yeah.
Some people may want to make it very explicit by saying this is the derivative
with subscripted,
why that means why is being held constant,
but next is buried.
But we don't have to write that because we know we got to coordinates.
If I'm changing one,
the other guy,
his wife.
So we won't be one right that
that's the partial a little bit.
So you can also move from here to here,
up and down and see how the function changes.
So I won't write the details.
You can define obviously a DFD why.
So one tells you how the function changes with X.
I should move along.
X other tells you how it changes it.
Why as you move along.
Why?
So let's get some practice.
So I'm going to write some function.
F equals x cubed y square.
That's a function of x and y.
You can write any.
Let's make a little more interesting.
Less why otherwise square.
That's some function of x and y.
So when I say the FDX,
the rule is find out how it varies with x keeping.
Why constant.
That means really treated like a constant.
Number five,
what will you do?
You have why was equal to five this will be 25 and it's not part of taking
derivatives because it's not changing.
And here it'll be just standing in front doing nothing.
We just take the [inaudible] treating Ysa construct.
You're supposed to do that here.
This is a bit of a two,
three x square.
Why?
So that's the extent of it too.
Okay.
Maybe we can take the why part.
Why Square?
Yes,
thank you.
Then I can take DFD why?
So then I look for wide changes.
This is too wide here.
So two x cubed,
y plus two y.
So that's the extent of it have been a partial white elevated.
Okay.
So then you can now take higher derivatives.
We know that from Calculus at one variable you can take the derivative of the
derivative.
So one thing you can think about is the two f the x square.
That really means take the d by the x off the d by Dx.
That's what it means.
First,
take a deliberative and take the deliberative off the date of it.
So let's see what I get here.
I already took the FDX.
I want to take that a bit too,
right?
That never would have x squared is two x.
So I get six x y square.
Then I can take the white delivered two of the white it.
You need to have the white square,
let's d by d y of DFT.
Why?
If you take the white that ever lived there,
you guys should keep an eye out for me when I do this,
I get this.
But now we have an interesting possibility you didn't have in one dimension,
which is to take the extent of it off the white end of it.
So I wanted to take d by d x off the FD.
Why that is written as d two f the XD.
Why?
Let's see what I get.
So I want the x derivative off the white end of it.
I go to this guy and take an extra two,
I get three x squared from there.
So I get six x squared y and that's it.
So it makes sure that the,
I got the proper x to have this.
I think that's fine.
Then I can also take d two f the YDX.
That means take the why derivative of the externalities.
Well,
here's the extra derivative.
Take the way that they were with that,
put it to why there and I get six x squared y.
So you're supposed to notice something.
If you wanted to know this,
you're not surprise.
You have never seen this before.
You will notice that the cross derivative wife followed by x and x followed by
why come up being equal.
That's a dental property of any reasonable function.
But it is never,
I mean you cannot call the mathematician straight help because they will always
find something where this one work.
Okay?
But if you write down any function that you are capable of writing down with
powers of aix and power,
so why and science and coastlines,
it'll always be true that you can take the cross state over those in either
order,
we'd get the same answer.
I'd like to give you a little bit of a feeling for why that is true.
It's true,
but it's helpful to know why it's true.
So let's ask the following question.
Let's take a function and
let's ask how much the function changes when I go from
some point x.
Y do another point.
X Plus Delta,
x,
y Plus Delta.
Why
I wanted to find the change in the function.
Yeah,
so I'm asking you what is f of x Plus Delta x,
y Plus Delta,
y minus F of x,
Y for small values and Delta x and Delta y,
the neighboring points.
What's the change?
So we are going to do it in two stages.
We introduced an intermediate point here who was coordinating this x Plus Delta,
x and Y
and I'm going to add and subtract the value of the function here.
Adding,
subtracting is three.
It doesn't cost anything,
so let's do that.
Then what do I get?
I get F of x Plus Delta,
x,
y Plus Delta,
y minus F of x Plus Delta,
x,
y
plus
F of x Plus
Delta X.
Come on.
Y minus F of X.
Y.
Okay.
I'm just saying the change of that guy might not.
This guy is the same as that minus this plus this minus that
trivial substitution,
but at write it this way because I look at the first entity here,
it looks like I'm just changing why I'm not changing x.
You agree?
So what will this be?
This is going to be the rate of change of the function with respect to x times
delta x and this,
yeah,
I'm sorry I got it wrong,
but the Spec to y times Delta y,
this one is the f x times built a x for change in the function.
If I add it all up,
I get the FDX Delta x list,
the FD.
Why Delta y,
what do you feel?
Pedantic,
you will notice this is something had to be real careful about what do you think
I'm referring to
in my notation?
Yes.
Uh,
meaning
but
oh,
but this is nothing to do dimension.
You see it's one number minus another number.
I put another number in between and in this function it's a function only have
uh,
here,
let me see.
X is not changing at all in why it's changing.
So it is DFD why Delta,
why I meant something else that is in fact a good approximation.
But that is one thing you should be careful about,
which has to do with where the debt of it.
Those are really taken
for the term here.
X Plus Delta x minus y minus F of X.
Y I took the deliberative at my starting point.
If you want,
I will say that the starting point x,
y
the second one when I came here and I want to move up,
I'm taking the derivative with respect to why are the new point,
the new point,
it's an x plus Delta x.
Come on.
Why so ever?
It is or not quite taken at the same point.
So you got to fix that.
And how do you fix that part?
You argue that,
well,
the derivative with respect to why is just another function of y,
right?
F as a function of why it's delivered as a function of x and y.
Everything is a function of x and y and we are saying this deliberate and it has
been computed at x plus delta x instead of x.
So it is going to be DFD why at x,
y plus the two FDX The y times a delta x.
In other words I'm saying they did ever do,
but this location is to deliver to that location plus the rate of change of the
derivative time to change next.
Now there was the deliberative itself is changing.
So if you put that together,
you find it is the FDX Delta x.
Let's DFD why Delta y where'd if I don't put any bars at anything,
it means at the starting point x,
y Plus d to f the x,
the y,
Delta x,
Delta y.
Now you've got to realize that when you're doing this calculus problems,
Delta x,
it's a tiny number of Delta where it's a tiny number.
Delta y is tiny,
tiny,
so normally we don't care about it.
I'd be done if you want it to be more accurate.
Of course you should keep that term in the first approximation,
but he worked work the first part of everything.
This will be your Delta f but if a little more ambitious,
but you keep track of the fact that derivative itself is changing.
You will keep that term,
but now that person comes along and says,
you know what?
I wanted to go like this.
I want to introduce as my new point intermediate point.
The one here,
it has a different value of y in the same accent.
Then I went horizontally.
Then I keep track of the changes.
What do you think that person will calculate for the change in the function?
That person will get exactly this part,
but the extra term that person will get will look like d two f,
D Why d?
X,
Delta,
Y,
Delta x.
If you just do the whole thing in your head,
you can see that I'm just exchanging the x and y roles,
so everything that happened with x and y here,
we'll come backwards why you're next,
but then the change between these two points that the change between these two
points,
then it doesn't matter whether they introduced an intermediate point here on an
intermediate point there.
Therefore these changes have to be equal.
This part,
if it's of course equal,
therefore you want that part to be equal.
Delta x,
Delta y is clearly delta y,
Delta x.
The consequence of that is need to FTX.
D Y is equal to d to f.
D why DX?
That's the reason it turns out when you take cross derivatives,
you get the same answer.
It comes from the fact.
If you say,
where does that result coming from?
It comes from the fact if you start at some point and you go to another point
and you asked for the change of the function,
the changes accumulating as you move,
you can move horizontally and vertically or we can move vertically and then
horizontally the chain of the function is a change in the function.
Got To get the same answer to both ways.
That's the reason.
That's the requirement that leads to this requirement.
No,
I will not be keeping track of functions to this accuracy.
In everything we do today we'll be keeping the leading powers in Delta x and
Delta y so you should bear in mind that if you make a movement in the x,
y plane,
which is delta x horizontally Delta,
why vertically then the chain of the function
is this
Dropbox it on debt because that's going to be,
this is just the naive generalization to two dimensions of what you know.
In one dimension you are saying,
look,
the function is changing because the independent variables x and y are changing
and the change in the function is one part which I blame on the attending
accent.
A second part with the blame on the changing.
Why an ad.
So you're worried about the fact that we are moving in the plane and the
vectors,
that's all correct.
But F is not a vector.
If it's just a number and it's changed has got two parts.
Okay.
So this is the basically all the mat we will need to do what I want to do today.
So let's now go back to our original goal,
which was the,
did I have something like the law of conservation of energy in two dimensions
instead of one?
So you remember what I did last time?
So I will remind you one more time what the trick was,
we found out that the change in the kinetic energy of some object is equal to
the work done by a force some f times Delta X.
And then if you add all the changes or whatever,
not the infinitesimal displacement,
but a macroscopic displacement that was given by f times DX.
And the FDA is dx from x one x two if f is a functional,
only have x from the rules of calculus can be written as a difference of a
function or this limit minus that limit and that was you have x one minus you
affects where you is.
That function.
Who's is [inaudible] with a minus sign is f.
That's what we did.
Then it's very simple.
Now to take the,
you wanted the left hand side,
let me see k one to the right hand side and you to the left hand side to get k
two plus two is Kayvon plus you want it.
That's conservation of energy.
You want to try the same thing in two dimensions.
That's your goal.
So first question is what should I use for the work done?
What expression should I use for the work done in two dimensions?
Because the force now is the vector forces,
not one number.
It's got an ex parte and the white part.
My displacement is also got an export in a white part and I can worry about what
I should use.
So I'm going to deduce the quantity I want to use for Delta w namely the tiny
work done,
which is an extension of this.
I'm going to demand that since I'm looking for a work energy Theorem,
I'm going to demand that you remember it in one dimension.
Delta,
k,
F Delta x.
If we divide by the time over which this happens,
I find DKD t is equal to force times velocity.
I'm going to demand that.
That's the power for stem.
For the last [inaudible] is what I call the power.
I'm going to look for dk d t in two dimensions of a body that's moving.
What's the day to day?
What's going to dig into these changing when a body is moving for that,
I need a formula for candidate energy formula for Kennedy Energy is going to be
again,
one half Mv Square.
I want that to be the same entity.
So I will choose it to be that,
but we square has got now we x squared plus y squared because you know whenever
you take a vector d Dennis length is the square root of the next parts where it
was a white patch where
any questions?
Okay,
so let's take the rate of change of this.
G K det again,
do you have to know your calculus?
What's the time?
Did it have it to a VX square?
Then the rule from is first take the database will be x squared with respect vx
just to Vieques.
Then take the deliver to Vieques with respect of time.
So you do the same thing for the second term to be y,
e y e d t and that gives me the tools.
Cancel gives me M Dvx,
v t times V,
x plus m VB.
Why d?
T t y.
This is the rate at which the kinetic energy of a body's changing.
So what's my next step?
Yes,
the half got canceled by the two here.
that's correct.
So what do we want to do is to recognize this,
this ama in the x direction,
because am times DVD,
t DVX,
dts Aix in this m times a y.
Therefore they're the forces in the x and y directions play,
right?
Fx,
VX,
let's y fee.
Why?
Yeah,
so the power,
when you go to two dimensions,
not very different from one dimension.
In one dimension,
you had only one force and you had only one velocity in two dimensions,
you've got an x and y components for each one and it becomes this.
So this is what I will define to be the power.
When a body is moving and the forces acting on it,
the forced us to components of velocity is two components.
This combination shall be called power,
but now let's multiply both sides by Delta t and write the change in kinetic
energy is equal to ethics.
You guys think about what happens when I multiply the x by Delta.
T VX is DXDT multi plank with Delta t just gives me the distance traveled and
the aesthetician let's f y Times d y.
So this is the plenty I'm want to work done by a force and a generalizes.
What we had here were done is forced time to delta x in two dimensions is Fx d x
plus y the y.
It's not a hard to guess that,
but the beauty is this combination.
Now you can say,
you know what,
I didn't have to do all this.
I could have always guessed that in two dimensions when you had an x and a y,
you obviously got add.
No,
there's nothing very obvious about it because this combination is no guaranteed
to have the property that if I call this the work done than it has.
The advantage that the work done is in fact the chain than Kennedy.
Kennedy.
I want to define work so that it's effect on kinetic energy is the same as in
one B.
Namely work done should be equal.
The change in Canada energy and the engineered that by taking the change and
kinetic energy,
seeing whatever it came out to and calling that the work.
Now,
I cannot go wrong,
but nobody noticed something repeating itself all the time,
which is that I had a vector ef,
which again write this I times Fx plus j times f y I had a vector of velocity
which is I times VX plus j Times v y.
Then I had a tiny distance mode by the particle,
which is eight times Dx plus j Times d y
the political moves from one point to another point.
The vector describing his location changes by this tiny vector.
It is just the step in the x direction time,
but a step in the way that extra times Jay,
so what you're finding is the fallen combination,
the excomm pointed at f times x component of V plus the white competitive f
names at white component of e r f component of x times the business moved in x
plus y competitive f times the displacement and why?
So we are running into the following combinations.
We are saying that seemed to be in all these problems,
two vectors.
I times x this day at time.
Say why a,
for example,
it could be the force that I'm talking about.
There's another vector B,
which is eight times bx plus deer times buy,
right?
For example,
this guy could be standing in port [inaudible].
This could be standing in for the v.
The combination that seems to appear very naturally is the combination a x,
B,
x.
Yeah,
let's say B.
Why
it appears to many times,
so I take it seriously.
Give that a name.
That name will be called the dot product of a B,
and this written like this.
Whenever something appears all the time,
you give it a name.
This is a dot B,
so for any two vectors,
a and B,
that will be the definition of a dot.
B.
Then the work done by a force F that displaces the particle by a tiny vector.
D R is f.
Dot.
D
particles moving in the x y plane from one incident at the next.
It can move from here to there.
That little guy is the Ar.
It's got a little bit horizontal and has got a little bit vertical.
That's why you build the are the force itself is some force,
which at that point need not pointed.
The direction in which you're moving.
It's some direction.
At each point,
the forest could have whatever value it likes.
So the dark product,
you know,
sometimes you learn the dark product as they expect me to say.
Why be why you can ask who thought about it?
Why is it an asset of quantity?
So here's one way you can understand why somebody would think of this particular
combination.
So once you've got the dot product,
you got to get a feeling for what it is.
First thing we realize is that if you take a dot product of a with itself,
then there's a x x plus a y,
a y,
which is x squared plus a white square,
which is the length of the vector a,
which you can either do or this way I'll just write it without an arrow.
So a dollar a day is a positive number that measures the length squared of the
victory.
Likewise B.
Dot.
B.
Now we have to ask ourselves,
what is a dot B?
Okay,
so somebody know what eight I'd be is.
Yep.
Okay,
so how do we know that?
How do we know its length of eight times length of B times costs and of the
angle you should follow from.
Is that an independent definition?
Notice that a consequence of this?
Yup.
You're right.
Using the wrong person.
Yes.
He said we can did bit using the law of course science and that's what I will
do.
Now,
in other words,
that definition would you may have learned about first is not independent of
this definition.
It's a consequence of this definition.
So let's see why that's true.
So let's draw two vectors here.
Yeah.
This air
and hear this beat,
it's got a length air.
It's got a link be this makes an angle data sub a with the x axis and that makes
an angle.
Data's a B with the x axis.
Yeah,
no.
Do you guys agree that the x component of a,
what's the horizontal part of a just Aiko sign data times a,
you must have seen lots of examples of that,
but then you did all the fours calculation in a y is equal to the length of a
time sign they disobey.
And likewise for B,
I don't feel like writing.
If you do that then A.
Dot B will be length of a length of B times go sign up date and time,
say course annotated times B,
uh,
plus sign data,
a sign and date of birth.
No.
Have you got to go back to your good old trig and it'll tell you this cost cost
plus sign sign is constipated a minus data B.
So you find it has length a length of B [inaudible] of data a minus data B.
Often people simply say that it's ab consigned data where it's understood that
data is the angle between the two vectors.
So the dot product that you learned,
you might,
I don't know which way it was introduced to you first,
but these are two equivalent definitions that dark product in one of them.
If you're thinking more in terms of the components to be a pat of numbers for a
and a pattern of numbers,
but B,
this definition of the dark product is very nice
if you're thinking of them as two little arrows pointing in different directions
than the other definition in which the lengths and the angle between them
appears.
That's more natural,
but numerically they are equal.
An important property of the dot product,
which you can check either way.
The dark product a with B plus c is proud product of a with B flat dark product
of a with c.
That just means you can open up the brackets with dot products as you can with
ordinary products.
No,
that's a very important property of the dark products,
so maybe I can ask somebody,
do you know one property,
significant property of the dot product?
Wow.
Oh,
okay.
That's an interesting,
I didn't think about it.
Yes.
One thing is if two vectors are perpendicular,
the dark product is zero because cost sign of 90 zero
but what I had in mind,
of course,
it's hard for me.
It's not fair.
I asked you some questions without saying what I'm looking for.
What can you say if you use a different set of axes?
Yep.
If you go to the rotated axes,
the components of the vector day will change.
We have done that,
the homework,
but and then the class components,
a B will also change.
Everything will get a prime,
but the combination x B experts Ayby when evaluated before or after.
We'll give the same answer because it's not so obvious when you write it this
way.
There's very obvious when you write it this way because it's clear to us if you
stand on your head or do you rotate the whole axes.
What you're looking for is the length of a,
which certainly doesn't change on your orientation or the length of B or the
angle between them.
The Angle Theta Aa will change with anger with the new x axis one be the same
angle,
but the new y axis one be the same.
Likewise for B,
but the angle between the vectors which an invariant properties,
something intrinsic to the two vectors doesn't change.
The dot product is an invasion.
This is a bit important notion.
When you learned a little city,
you will find,
you have one observers saying something and other observers saying something,
they will disagree on a lot of things,
but there are a few things they will all agree on.
Those few things will be analog of a dot.
B.
So it's very good to have this part of it very clear in your head.
That's part of elementary vector analysis should be clear in your head.
Okay,
so
any,
any questions about this?
So if you want geometrically the work done by a force when it moves the body or
distance the are a vector.
Dr Is the full length of the force.
The distance traveled times the core sine of the angle between the force and the
displacement vector.
Okay,
I'm almost ready for business because what is my goal?
I find out that in a tiny displacement f.
Dot.
D R,
I start from somewhere.
I go to a neighboring place at distance.
The auto way,
the change in Kennedy,
Kennedy is F.
Dot.
D are so let me make a big trip.
Okay.
Let me make a trip in the x y plane made up of a whole bunch of little segments
in each one of which I calculate this
and to add them all up
on the left hand side,
the Delta case,
this whole thing was defined so that it's equal to Delta K,
right?
Delta K was equally this.
That's equal to all that.
If you add all the delta case,
it's very clear what you will get.
You will get the kinetic energy at the end minus Kennedy gonna do at the
beginning.
On the right hand side you are told to add f.
Dot.
D are for every tiny segment.
Well that is different written symbolically as this is the notation we use
calculus.
That just means if you want to go from a to B along some path,
you chop up the path of the tiny pieces.
Each tiny segment,
if it's small enough to be approximated by a tiny vector d are then take the dot
product off that Little d r with the force at that point,
which means length of half time,
the length of the segment,
times cosine of the angle,
add them all up.
Then,
uh,
somebody will say,
well,
your segments are not short enough for me to chop it up some water and chop it
up some more.
Chop it up till your worst critic has been silenced.
That's the limit in which you can write the answer as this integral.
Just like in Calculus,
when you integrate a function,
you take,
you take tiny intervals.
Dell tags multiplay f by Dell tax,
but then you make the intro once more and more numerous and less and less widen.
The limit of that is the area under the graph and that's called integral.
You do the same thing now into dementia.
So
now maybe it will be true just like in one dimension that the integral of this
function,
would it be something that depends on the end point?
I'm just going to call it you.
One Lane is youtube or some function you just like it wasn't one dimension.
Okay.
If that is true then my job is done because then I have cared one plus you want
his kid to plus youth too.
Okay,
so then when I'm,
when I'm looking for the law of conservation of energy,
I got to go to some calculus book and I got asked the calculus book look in one
dimension you told me the integral of f from start to end is really the
difference.
Another function g at the end minus to start with g is that function was
delivered was f maybe that is going to be some other magic function.
You in two dimensions related to f in some way so that this integral is again
given by a difference of something there minus something here.
If that is the case,
then you can rearrange it and get this,
what you will find that it's not meant to be that simple.
So again,
has anybody heard rumors about why it may not be that simple?
What could go wrong?
Okay,
so you,
yes.
Uh,
okay.
That's probably correct.
But say it in terms of what we know what can go wrong.
I'm saying in one day and I did an integral integral was the difference of two
numbers,
right?
And therefore I got CarePlus use capable.
So something should go wrong somewhere here.
When I say this integral from start to finish is a difference.
The only of the ending point minus the starting point.
Is that reasonable or could imagine that depending on something else,
yes.
Wait,
we'll say you have one of your courses,
you take a certain path from 0.1 to 0.2,
it should,
um,
you should have like the same kinetic and potential energy.
But if you take a longer tap and there's friction involved with that,
again,
absolutely correct.
It's true that if you've got friction,
this is not going to work.
It doesn't even work in one day,
in one day.
If I start here and end here and why do you about friction?
Fed went straight from here to here to some amount of friction.
If I just went back and forth 97 times and then I ended up that is 97 times more
friction.
So we agreed that if it's friction,
this is not going to work.
But the trouble is friction was the force was not function,
only have x and y.
It depended on the direction of motion.
But now I grant you that the force is not a function of velocity.
It's only a function of where you are.
Again,
something still be wrong.
Well,
let me ask you the following question.
Now that person does this.
Yes.
You think that person should do the same amount of work
because the forest is now integrated on a longer path.
So you've seen one dimension.
There's only one way to go from here to there this go,
right?
That's why I have a new light and integrally,
The lower limit and the upper limit and you don't say any more because there's
only one way in one day to go from x one,
two x two in two dimensions that are thousands of ways to go from one point to
another point.
You can wander all over the place and you end up here that for this integral,
even if I say the starting point is our one ending point is our two at this odd
one,
that's art too.
It's not adequate.
What do you think I should attach to this integration?
What other information should they give?
What more should I specify?
Yep.
Along those,
no,
it's not a closed path.
I'm going from one to two.
What more should I tell you before you can even find the work done?
Yes,
you're going,
yep.
See which path you're going in because you can,
you feel only have two points,
one and two then that is a work done,
but it depends on the path.
The work depends on the path.
Then the answer cannot be a function of you on mine minus you cannot just be one
way you want minus you to say is tell me about your wedding.
Tell me where you start.
And that difference of some function you between those two points,
is the work done?
In other words,
I'm asking you to think critically about whether this equality really could be
true.
This is some function u in the x y plane evaluated at one point minus the other
point.
This is on a path of joining those two points.
But I have not told you which path and I can draw any path they're like with
those same end points.
And you got to realize that it's very unreasonable to expect that no matter
which path you take,
you will get the same answer.
Okay?
So you might think that I'm creating a straw man because it's going to turn out
by some magic that no matter what force you take,
somehow the due the magic of mathematics,
the integrator will depend only on the end points.
Uh,
but that's not the case.
Generally.
That won't happen.
So I have to show you that.
So I'm going to start by asking you for a,
give me a number from one to three.
Two.
Okay.
Then I want a few more numbers.
Uh,
now that number
from one to three.
Okay.
All right then two more
mark.
You pick a number.
Good,
thank you.
Then I need one more.
Yes.
One,
two,
three,
a number from one to three.
Two.
Very good.
Okay,
so you pick these numbers randomly.
I'm going to take a force which looks like I times x squared y cubed,
let j times x,
y squared.
Okay.
I put the powers based on what you guys give.
So we pick the force in two dimensions out of a hat.
Now let's ask,
is that true for this force that the work done and going from one point to
another depends only on the path or does it depend?
I mean it depends only on endpoints that does it depend in detail on how you go
from the end point?
Yes.
You all have to understand before you copy anything down where we are going with
this,
what's the game plan?
So let me tell you one more time because you can copy this all you want.
It will get you nowhere.
You should feel that you know where I'm going,
but the details remain to be shown what you should have an idea of what's
happening if you try to generalize the work energy theorem to two dimensions.
This is what happened so far.
You found the definition of work which has the property that the work done is
the change in Kennedy Energy.
Then you added up all the changes of Kennedy Energy and added up all the work
done and you said k two minus k one is integral of f.
Dot.
Dr That's guaranteed to be true.
That won't that just based on Newton's laws.
What is tricky is the second equality that that integral is the difference in a
function calculated at one end point minus the other end point.
If that was true,
if the integral dependent only on the end points,
then it cannot depend on the path that you take.
If it depends on the path.
Every path you take within the same two end points will give different numbers.
So the answer cannot simply be you one minus youtube first time trying to
convince you through an example that I selected randomly that if you took a
random force and found the work done along one path or another path,
you will in fact get two different answers.
Okay?
That's the first thing to appreciate that that's a problem.
So generally took at random force,
not a frictional force.
The force depends only on location,
not velocity.
It will not be possible to define a potential energy nod when it'd be possible
to find a care plus you so that it doesn't change.
So it's got to take a very special force for with the answer depends only on the
starting and ending point and not have the path to show you that such as that's
a special situation.
I'm taking a genetic situation,
namely a force manufactured by this class without any prior consultation with me
and I will show you that for that.
For us,
the answer is going to depend on how you go.
So let's take that force and let's find the work done and going from the origin.
The 0.11
so I'm going to take two paths.
One path.
I'm going to go horizontally tell I'm below the point that I'm going straight
up.
So let's find the work done.
Then I go this way.
So you again,
you should be thinking all the time.
You should say,
if this guy got struck by lightning,
can I do anything or am I just going to say,
well,
I don't know what he was planning to do.
You got to have some idea.
What I'm going to do,
and we're going to integrate F.
Dot.
D are first on the horizontal segment.
Then on the vertical segment for some vector you give me at the point x and Y,
I'll plug in some numbers.
I'll get something times I him,
something times Jay maybe pointing like that.
At this point that's f that's given,
but now when I'm moving horizontally,
my displacement,
Dr has only got a dx part.
I hope you see that every step I move,
there's no DUI in it.
It's all horizontal.
So f.
Dot.
Dr
Just becomes Fx Dx
because there is no DUI when you move horizontally.
So when they do the integral,
you have FX dx.
Fx happens to be x squared,
y cube,
dx x going from zero to one.
Now what do I do with White Cube?
You all know how to integrate the function of x times DX.
What do I do with White Cube?
What do you think it means?
What me?
What should they do with why
you evaluate why on that path at that point?
Well,
it turns out throughout this horizontal segment,
why is zero
so this has gone basically the point is very simple.
When you move horizontally,
you're working against the [inaudible] forces doing work,
but on the x axis and Y is zero.
That is no horizontal force that way.
There's nothing to do.
Now you're coming to this segment,
I think you all agree the distance traveled is j Times d y.
So I have to have another segment.
The second part of my trip,
which is f y Times d,
Y,
and why he goes from zero to one and a,
the white component is x,
Y,
z squared.
D why or why?
It goes from to one but now on the entire line that I'm moving up and down x is
equal to one.
Do you see that x is a constant on the line so you could replace x by one and y
Square d why is white cube over three and the work done is therefore one third
Jews.
So the work done in going first to the right and then to the top is one third.
You can also go straight up and then horizontally by a similar trick.
I won't do that.
Nobody cause I want to show you something else that's useful for you.
I'm going to pick another path which is not just made up of x and y segments.
Then it's very easy to do this.
I'm going to pick another,
another way to go from zero zero two one one which is on this curve.
This is the curve y equals a x wave.
First of all,
you got to understand the curve way.
Collect square goes through the two points I'm interested in.
Okay.
If a good way equal to five x squared,
it doesn't work.
But this guy goes through zero,
zero and goes through one one and I'm asking you if I did the work done by the
force along that segment,
what is the integral of f.
Dot.
D are,
so let's take a tiny portion of that looks like this,
right?
That's Dr misguided dx and there's got to d y.
Yeah.
Now you notice that as this segment because very small d y over dx is a slope
for
the y will be the y divided by DX times.
DX.
In other words,
DX and dys,
not independent.
If you're moving in a particular direction,
I hope you understand that you want to fall a certain curve.
If you step to the right by some amount,
you've got to step vertically by certain amounts of you're moving on that curve.
That's why when you do the calculate the work done dx and dy,
why are not independent?
So what do you really want is f x,
Dx,
let's f y,
t y,
but for Dui I'm going to use the Y,
dx times.
DX.
In other words,
every segment Delta y that you have is related to the delta x.
You took horizontally so that you stay on that curve.
So everything depends only on Dex,
but what am I putting inside integral?
Let's take FX.
The x component is x squared y cubed
on this curve.
Why is to x squared?
So you really write x squared and Y is equal to x squared.
That is extra this sixth.
This x cubed is really white written in terms of x.
Then I have to write f y which is x times y squared,
which is extra.
The fourth time's DYD x.
We just do x.
So I get here from all of this extra,
the eighth plus two extra.
The five.
Yeah.
Did I make a mistake somewhere?
One mean,
did I hear
here?
Oh here.
Oh,
extra the sixth tonight.
Thank you.
I was that.
Thanks for wanting that.
You have to watch it.
Uh,
so now what do I get extra?
The eighth integral is actually the nine over nine that gives me one nine
because x is going from zero to one.
The next thing is extra.
The seven over seven which is two times.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm not paying too much attention to this because I know it's not one third.
Okay.
There's no way this guy's going to be one third.
That's all I cared about.
So I'm showing you that if we took a random force,
the work done is dependent on the path for this force.
You cannot define a potential energy in one dimension.
Any force that was not friction.
I'll overdo to define a potential energy and higher dimension.
You just cannot do that.
That's the main point.
So if you're looking for a conservative fiscal conservative force is a force for
which you can define a potential energy.
It has the property that the work done and going from a to B or wanted to is
independent or have you got from one to two and the f the One force that the
class generated pretty much randomly is not a conservative force because the
work done was pat dependent.
So what we have learnt,
in fact,
I'll keep this portion here,
if you're looking for a conservative force,
a force was answer,
does not depend on how you went from start to finish
then.
Yep.
To some our dream up some force so that if you did this Integro the answer does
not depend on the path you realize.
That looks at really miraculous because we just wrote down her arbitrary forced
that we all cooked up together with these exponents.
And the answer depends on the path.
And I guarantee you if we just arbitrarily write down some force,
it won't work.
So maybe there is no law of conservation of energy in more than one dimension.
So how am I going to search for the force that will do the job?
Are that at least some forces for which this will be true?
Yes.
No,
but see,
the point is you got to first write down a force next white plain.
Then I should be free to pick any two points and connect them anywhere like,
and the answer shouldn't depend on how I connected them.
Only then you can have conservation of energy.
I hope you all understand that fact,
so I'm seeing a genetic force on the x.
Y plane doesn't do that.
Then we ask,
can that ever be an answer?
It is so demanding.
Yes.
Right,
right.
So he's saying,
I know force the force of gravity in fact happens to have the property that the
work done by the force of gravity does not depend on the path.
We will see why that is true,
but you see what I want this to ask instead of math instead of machine that'll
manufactured conservative forces and I'm going to tell you that is I would show
you a machine that'll produce a large number of infinite number of conservative
forces and I'll show you how to produce them.
Here is the trick.
The trick is instead of taking a force and finding if there's a potential that
will come from it by doing integrations,
let me assume that it's a potential.
Then I will ask what force I can associate with the potential and here's the
answer.
Answer this.
Step one,
pick any you have accent,
why
you pick the function first.
That function is going to be your potential energy.
It's been anointed even before we do anything.
But then from the potential I want you to manufacture the following force.
I want you to find the I want the force that I'm going to find is going to be
having an x component which the deliver to a view with respect to x and it's
going to have a white component with the delivered to with you with respect to
why
that is.
Step two in fact,
the claim now is this force is going to be a conservative force
and in fact this potential energy associated with it will be the function you
use started.
So how do I know that?
So for example,
I'm saying suppose you equal do Xyq then FX is equal to minus d you DX,
which is equal to minus white cube and F Y which this minus the u d y would be
minus three x y square.
The claim is if you put i-times FX and daytime safe,
why?
The answer will not depend on how have you gone from start to finish.
So let me prove that to you.
Here's the proof,
the change in the function u in the x y plane,
you guys remember I might telling you is dod x Times Dx Plus U D Times d y.
That's the old thing of mathematical preliminaries,
which was done somewhere.
I forgot.
Here it says see a Delta Alpha Delta F del Tech's time,
Delta x,
Delta,
Delta.
Why I played to the function you,
but who is this?
You know what?
This is what's going on here.
The U Dx Dx.
This is FX with the minus sign.
That's Fyi,
the minus sign.
Therefore this is equal to minus F.
Dot.
D.
R.
Right,
because we agreed the force that I want to manufactured.
Is it related to you in this fashion?
If you add all the changes,
right?
10 side becomes the integral of F.
Dot.
D R and the left hand side becomes the summer fall.
The delta use with a minus sign.
Yeah,
add all the delta.
Use the minus sign that it just become you at 1 million as you were too.
It is cooked up so that f.
Dot.
D R is actually at the change in the function in you that the,
if you say,
what was the trick that you did?
I cooked up a force by design so that F.
Dot.
D R was a change in a certain function.
You if added all the F.
Dot.
D ours.
I'm going to get a change in the function.
You from start to finish.
It's gotta be you one minus Youtube.
Yeah,
so I don't know how else I can say this.
Maybe the way to think about it is,
wait,
do this,
wait a certain integros not depend on how you took the path.
Right.
Let me ask you a different question.
Forget about integros.
You are on top of some hilly mountain.
We have a starting point.
You have an ending point.
Okay.
I started at the starting point and I walked to the ending point.
Every portion of my walk,
I keep track of how many feet I'm claiming.
That's like my delta.
You.
I add them all up.
At the end of the day,
the height change will be the top of the mountain minus bottom of the mountain
height of the mountain.
You go on a different path.
You don't go straight for the summit,
you loop around and you coil and you wind down,
you go up,
you do this and you also end up at the summit.
If you kept track of how long you walked,
it won't be the same as me,
but if you also kept track of how many feet you claimed you added them all up,
what answered will you get will get the same answer I got.
Therefore,
if what you were keeping track of as the height change in a function than the
sum of all the height changes will be simply the total high chain,
which is the height at the end minus height at the beginning.
Therefore starting with the height function by taking his,
if you manufacture to force,
this will be none other than the fact of adding up the changes.
Okay.
And that's why this will be kid do minus k one and then you would get k one plus
you want this kid to plus you too.
I hope you understand how conservative forces are not impossible to get.
In fact,
for every function you have x and y you can think of,
you can manufacture that kind of separate of course.
So you may ask Pauline question maybe that are other ways to manufacture the
conservative force and you just thought of one and the answer is no.
Not only is this a machine that generates conservative forces,
my two step algorithm,
because you and take his directives,
every conservative force you get is necessarily obtained by taking derivatives
with respect to x and y have some function you and that you will be the
potential energy associated with that force.
So they've been,
that force alone acts on a body,
that candidate plus that potential will not change.
Finally,
you remember that,
uh,
when the class pick a certain force,
we tie rod here.
I went on a limb and I said,
I'm going to do the integral of this force along this path and that path and I'm
going to get different answers and show you we have a problem.
What if the force he had given me was actually a conservative force?
Then I would be embarrassed because then I will find after all the work,
this will turn out to be again,
one third,
so I had to make sure right away that the force is not conservative.
And how can you tell?
One way to say it is ask yourself could that be some function?
You who's exited with two have this was this and who's why that we do is that
you can probably convince yourself,
no function's going to do it for you because if you look at next date of it,
they should have lost a part of x here.
That means if you just took the wind out of active to go here,
you should have more powers of xls,
powers of white,
but this is just the opposite way.
So we know this couldn't have come from you,
but that is a better test.
Instead of building all that instead of saying,
I'm satisfied that this doesn't come from taking [inaudible] for you by looking
at possible use and not being satisfied because maybe I'm not clever enough.
That is the mechanical way to tell mechanical way to tell is the following.
Um,
maybe I want you guys think for a second about what the recipe,
maybe if air force came from a function you by taking directive as written up
there,
what can you say about the components of that force from the fact yes.
Right,
so that we know that for every function you the cross at equal,
but the ordinary derivatives are just the f x and f y then for d two you over d
why d x is really d by d y of ethics and I want that to be equal to the by the x
of f y good.
That would then be d to You over the d y.
In other words,
if the four satisfies this condition,
the white data at Fx is the extent of it,
of f y,
then it has the right pedigree to be a conservative force.
Because if a force came from a function you by taking derivatives,
the simple acquirement that across data does that equal for any function you
tells me.
See if I take the white that ever affects,
I'm taking d two You DX,
d y and he had taking d two [inaudible] d why d x?
And they must be equal.
So that's the diagnostic.
If I give you a force and I asked you,
is it conservative,
you simply take the way that avoidable affects and the exit of Fyi.
And if they match,
you don't as conservative.
So I got to summarize by saying the following thing in two dimensions.
There are indeed many,
many forces for which a potential energy can be defined,
but every one of them has an ancestor,
which is simply a function,
not a vector,
but a scalar function on ordinary function of x and y in the forest is obtained
by taking x and y databases of their function.
The exited Ebitda with a minus sign is called ethics.
And the way that I would have is called F y.
Okay?
So let's take the most popular example is the force of gravity near the surface
of the earth.
The force of gravity.
We know it's minus M G G
it says gay conservative.
Yes,
because exited with this vanishes.
Okay.
And the way that it would have effects,
you don't even have to worry because that is no FX,
just clearly conservative.
Then you can ask what is the potential you that led to this?
Well,
the U D Y with a minus sign had to be minus AMG and the UDX had to be zero.
So the function that will do the job.
Yes,
AMG,
why you can also have empty why plus 96 we will not add those constants because
in the end and the law of Conservation of energy,
k one plus you want his kid to please you to adding a 96 to both sides doesn't
do anything.
So this means when a body is moving in the gravitational field,
one half MV squared plus m g y before it's the same as one half MV squared plus
AMG.
Why after?
Yeah,
no,
you knew this already when you're moving up and down the white direction.
But what I'm telling you is this is true in two dimensions.
So I'll give you a final example so you guys can go home and think about it.
That is the roller coaster.
So yes,
the roller coaster,
it has a,
it looks like this.
This is x.
This is the height of the roller coaster,
but at every excess a certain heights or why is the function of x,
and it looks like this,
it just the profile of the rollercoaster,
but that is also the potential energy you,
because for multiply this by AMG rally to scale the graph AMD it looks the same.
So take a photograph of a roller coaster multiplied the height in meters by Amg
is going to still look the look like the rollercoaster.
That is my potential energy for this problem.
And the claim is that Kennedy plus potential will not change.
So k plus u is a constant,
let's call the constant e.
So if a trolley begins here at the top,
what does historical energy,
he's got potential energy equal with the height.
It's got no kinetic energy,
total energy.
In fact,
it's just as height and total energy cannot change as a trolley goes up and
down,
so you draw a line at that height and call it the total energy.
You started this guy off of that energy.
That energy was always be the same.
What that means is if you're somewhere here,
since that is your potential energy,
that is your kinetic energy's very nicely read off from this graph to read the
same total.
Yeah.
Plus you oscillate up and down.
You gain and lose kinetic and potential.
When you come here,
your potential energy is almost your whole energy,
but it got a little bit of candidate energy.
That means your rollercoaster is still moving.
When it comes here with the remaining kinetic energy,
you can have a roller coaster who's energy is like,
this is a release from rest here.
If it's really from rest here,
that's the total energy and historical energy lion looks like this.
That means if you released it here,
it'll come down,
pick up speed,
slow down,
pick up speed again and come to this point.
It must stop and turn it around because at that point the potential energy is
equal,
the total energy and there is no Kennedy,
Kennedy.
That means you stopped.
That means you're turning it on.
It'll rattle back and forth.
By the way,
according to the laws of quantum mechanics,
it can do something else.
Maybe you guys know,
you know what else it can do if it starts here,
yes,
it can suddenly find yourself here
and that's not allowed by classical mechanics because to do that,
it has to go over the hump.
Look what's happening at the hump and it got more kinetic energy than I have
total energy.
I'm sorry,
I've got more potential energy than I have total energy that miss kinetic energy
is negative.
That's not possible because one half MV squared can never be negative.
So quantum theory allows those forbidden processes and it's called tunneling,
but for us,
the roller coaster problem,
you would just turn it on.
There's one thing I want you to think about before you go.
You should not have simply accepted the law of conservation of energy in this
problem because gravity is not the only force acting on this.
What else is acting on this roller coaster?
Pardon me.
No friction than what you normally the force of the track.
Look,
if I didn't want to have anything but gravity.
Here's the roller coaster ride you guys will love.
Just push you over the edge.
Okay?
That conserves energy and it's got no track and he's got the only gravitation
forces.
You can happily use this formula.
Why am I paying all this money?
Because there's another force acting on it.
But that force,
if it's not frictional,
isn't necessarily perpendicular to the motion of the trolley and the
displacement of the trolleys along the track.
So f.
Dot.
D are vanishes.
So I'll conclude by telling you the correct thing to do would be to say k two
minus k one is the integral level.
All the forces divided into force due to the track and the force due to gravity.
Yes,
Fort Stewart,
the track is zero.
I mean it's not zero,
but that would dot product with the Arctic zero because FMD are perpendicular
for that reason.
You drop that and the force of gravity is cooked up so that it becomes you one
minus youth too.
And that's what we used.
Okay.
One challenge.
You guys can go home and do this.
Take any force in two dimensions.
F
Yeah.
It is padded a little to the direction where you are measured from the origin
times.
Any function of the distance from the audits.
Okay,
sure.
We convince yourself that this force is a conservative force by applying the
test I gave you and the trick is to use x and y instead of our,
take this force,
write it down in terms of x and y.
Take the cross derivatives and you can see it's conservative.
So any radial force.
Yep.
Oh,
here.
This is the force which you should try your thing.
And gravity is a special example of this.
Yeah.
Judging from the class reaction and the stunned and shocked.
Look,
a lot of few people,
maybe this material is new,
so you should think about it.
Talk about it.
Go to discussion section a,
but this is the level at which you should understand energy conservation in the
course.
Like this.